[Music]
young hollywood is mourning the death of
actor and model
daniel mickelson have a great day
[Music]
on monday daniel's sister and model
meredith mickelson
took to instagram to reveal her brother
had passed away
over 4th of july weekend he was 23 years
old
meredith writes in the caption to know
him was to love him he was the happiest
brightest smiley most sunshine human to
exist
and i'm so happy god chose me to be his
sister for his whole
amazing life
[Music]
details on what led to daniel's death
have not been revealed
but many of his famous friends have paid
tribute
stars like jordan woods and patrick
schwarzenegger offered their support to
meredith
writing praying for you along with
emilia hamlin who wrote
i love you forever daniel meanwhile
paris hilton and kaia gerber took to
their instagram stories
paris paid her respects writing you were
such a light
along with this video of their last
memory together
kaya gerber posted a heartfelt caption
in her insta story
reminiscing on when they came up with
their own secret language
i wish we could go back there i wish we
were still talking in sentences that
probably annoyed everyone else but made
us crack up
every time but the most touching tribute
was from daniel's girlfriend
maddie haley the two celebrated their
one year anniversary
in may
maddie credits daniel as her guardian
angel writing quote
i wish i could call you right now and
hear you tell me everything is going to
be okay
i wish my plans to spend the rest of my
life with you weren't stripped away from
me like this
i wish i could tell you how much i love
you and i wish i got the chance to say
goodbye
i'm not sure how i'm going to get
through this but i'm going to be strong
for you because i know it's what you
would have wanted
[Music]
i love you so much
[Music]
you